What do polls tell us about sexual
harassment? When women are asked whether
they have ever experienced harassment,
polls give us responses ranging from a
low of 42 percent in one poll to a high
of 60 percent in another. Fewer, around 30
percent of women in recent polls, say
that they have been sexually harassed at
work. There is positive news in a new
survey: A large majority think their
workplaces take the issue very seriously.
That's important because around
two-thirds believe that recent
allegations against high profile men
indicate a widespread problem in society,
and not isolated incidences. For the most
part, men and women agree on what
constitutes harassment, though in most
cases men are less likely to call a
behavior harassment than women are. Lewd,
aggressive, or threatening behavior is
clearly seen as harassment; flirtatious
actions less so. When an issue catches
fire like this one has, it's important to
take care in interpreting early poll
results, but the polls released thus far
present a fairly consistent picture of
attitudes about harassment.
What do you think about recent news stories about
sexual harassment? Are they isolated
incidents, or are they more widespread?
Let us know your comments. Also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.